Estoy muy, muy emocionado de estar aquí hoy,
porque les mostrare algo que está, literalmente, listo para salir del
laboratorio, y estoy realmente contento que ustedes estén entre los primeros en
verlo en persona, porque honestamente creo que esto cambiará
-- realmente cambiará -- la manera en la que interactuamos con las máquinas de ahora en adelante.
Ahora, éste es una mesa de dibujo de proyección trasera. Mide aproximadamente 36 pulgadas de ancho,
y está equipada con un sensor multi-táctil. Los sensores táctiles normales que
pueden ver, en un kiosco o en pizarras interactivas,
sólo pueden registrar un punto de contacto a la vez.
Esta mesa les permite tener múltiples puntos al mismo tiempo.
Puede usar mis dos manos, puedo ejecutar acciones coordinadas,
y puedo seguir aumentando y usar los 10 dedos si quisiera.
Así, de este modo.
Ahora, la sensibilidad multi-táctil no es completamente nueva.
Personas como Bill Buxton han estado jugando con esto desde los 80's.
Sin embargo, el enfoque que he construido es de alta resolución,
bajo costo, y probablemente lo más importante, muy escalable.
Entonces, la tecnología, sabrán, no es lo más emocionante de esto,
exceptuando probablemente su renovada accesibilidad.
Lo que es realmente interesante es lo que pueden hacer con esto,
y los tipos de interfaces que se pueden construir sobre ella. Entonces, veamos.
Por ejemplo, tenemos una aplicación de lámpara de lava. Ahora, como pueden ver,
puedo usar ambas manos para apretar y juntar
las manchas. Puedo inyectar calor al sistema,
o separarlo con dos de mis dedos.
Es completamente intuitivo; no hay manual de instrucciones.
La interfaz prácticamente desaparece.
Esto empezó como salvapantallas que uno de los estudiantes del Ph. D.
en nuestro laboratorio, Ilya Rosenberg, construyó. Pero creo que su verdadera identidad aparece acá.
Ahora, lo que es genial respecto al sensor multi-táctil es que
podría estar haciendo esto con todos los dedos,
pero, por supuesto, multi-táctil también significa, inherentemente, multi-usuario.
Entonces, Chris podría estar aquí interactuando con otra parte de la lava,
mientras yo juego por este lado. Pueden imaginar una nueva herramienta escultórica,
donde yo estoy calentando algo, volviéndolo maleable,
y después dejándolo enfriar y solidificándolo en un estado particular.
Google debería tener algo así en su lobby. (Risas).
Les mostraré algo -- un ejemplo algo más concreto, mientras esto carga.
Ésta es una caja de luz para fotógrafos.
De nuevo, puedo usar mis dos manos para interactuar y mover las fotos.
Pero lo que es aún más genial es que si uso dos dedos,
puedo agarrar una foto y estirarla de esta manera con mucha facilidad.
Puedo moverla, acercarla y girarla sin esfuerzo.
Puedo hacer eso con ambas manos,
o puedo hacerlo sólo con dos dedos de cada una de mis manos.
Si tomo el lienzo, puedo hacer más o menos lo mismo -- estirarlo.
Puedo hacerlo simultáneamente, lo sostengo
y agarro otro, estirándolo de esta manera.
De nuevo, la interfaz simplemente desaparece.
No hay manual. Esto es exactamente lo que esperarían,
especialmente si no han interactuado con un computador antes.
Ahora, cuando existen iniciativas como el computador portátil de 100 dólares,
Me estremezco con la idea de introducir a toda una nueva generación
de personas a la computación con la interfaz estándar de ratón y ventanas.
Yo pienso que esta es la manera en la que deberíamos interactuar con las máquinas
desde este momento. (Aplausos)
Ahora, por supuesto, puedo sacar un teclado.
Puedo moverlo, ponerlo allá arriba.
Obviamente, esta es una especie de teclado estándar,
pero por supuesto, puedo escalarlo para que funcione bien con mis manos.
Y eso es bastante importante, porque no hay ninguna razón en estos días por la que
debamos estar confinados a un dispositivo físico.
Eso lleva a cosas malas, como LER. (Lesiones por Esfuerzo Repetitivo)
Tenemos tanta tecnología estos días que
las interfaces deben empezar a adaptarse a nosotros.
Se ha invertido tan poco en mejorar
la manera en la que interactuamos con las interfaces.
Lo más probable es que este teclado sea en realidad la dirección incorrecta para continuar.
Pueden imaginar, en el futuro, a medida que desarrollamos este tipo de tecnología,
un teclado que siga su mano mientras se aleja,
y anticipe inteligentemente qué tecla están tratando de presionar.
¿No es esto genial?
Audiencia: ¿Donde está tu laboratorio?
Jeff Han: Soy un investigador de la Universidad de Nueva York (NYU).
Aca hay un ejemplo de otro tipo de aplicación. Puedo crear estas pelotitas.
La aplicación recordará los trazos que realizo. Desde luego, puedo hacerlo con ambas manos.
Es sensible a la presión, como notarán.
Pero lo entretenido es, nuevamente, que como les mostré antes, con un gesto de dos dedos puedo
hacer zoom rápidamente. No tienen que cambiar a otra herramienta
o usar una herramienta de lupa;
pueden hacer cosas continuamente en múltiples escalas reales, todo al mismo tiempo.
Puedo crear cosas grandes, pero puedo volver rápidamente a
donde comencé, y hacer cosas aún más pequeñas.
Ahora, esto será muy importante a medida que nos involucremos con cosas como
la visualización de datos. Por ejemplo, creo que todos disfrutamos la charla de Hans Rosling,
y él puso mucho énfasis en algo en lo que he estado pensando por mucho tiempo:
tenemos todos estos datos geniales, pero por alguna razón, simplemente están ahí.
No los estamos usando. Y creo que una de las razones, es porque
-- tendremos el apoyo de cosas como gráficas y herramientas de visualización e inferencia.
Pero pienso que una gran parte de eso será comenzar a contar con mejores interfaces,
para poder acceder a este tipo de información, sin dejar de pensar en el panorama global.
Déjenme mostrarles otra aplicación. Esta se llama WorldWind.
Es desarrollada por NASA. Es un tipo de -- todos hemos visto Google Earth;
esta es una versión de código abierto de eso mismo. Hay plug-ins que permiten
cargar distintos conjuntos de datos que NASA ha recolectado durante años.
Pero como pueden ver, puedo usar los mismos gestos con dos dedos
para bajar y acercarme a la perfección. De nuevo, no hay una interfaz.
Realmente permite que cualquiera se acerque -- y, hace justamente lo que esperas que haga,
Nuevamente, acá no hay una interfaz. La interfaz desaparece.
Puedo cambiar a diferentes vistas de datos. Eso es lo genial de esta aplicación.
Ahí lo tienen. NASA es genial. Tienen estas imágenes hiper-espectrales
que están falsamente coloreadas para que puedan -- es muy útil para determinar el uso vegetativo. Bueno, volvamos.
Ahora, lo mejor de las aplicaciones de cartografía --
no es el 2D, es el 3D. Entonces, nuevamente, con una interfaz multi-punto
pueden hacer un gesto como este -- para que puedan inclinar la cámara,
No está relegada al movimiento y al paneo 2D.
Ahora, este gesto que hemos desarrollado, funciona colocando dos dedos en la superficie,
definiendo un eje de inclinación, y puedo inclinar arriba y abajo de esa forma.
Fue algo que se nos ocurrió en el momento,
y probablemente no sea lo correcto,
pero hay tantas cosas interesantes que se pueden hacer con este tipo de interfaz.
Es muy entretenido jugar con ella también. (Risas)
Y lo último que quería mostrarles --
Estoy seguro que todos podemos pensar en muchas aplicaciones de entretenimiento
que se pueden hacer con esto.
Estoy algo más interesado en el tipo de aplicaciones creativas que se pueden hacer.
Aquí hay una aplicación muy simple -- Puedo dibujar una curva.
Y cuando la cierro, se convierte en un personaje.
Pero lo genial, es que puedo añadir puntos de control.
Y lo que puedo hacer es manipularlos con mis dos dedos al mismo tiempo.
Y se pueden dar cuenta de lo que hace.
Es como una marioneta, donde puedo usar
cuantos dedos tenga para dibujar y hacer --
Ahora, hay un montón de matemáticas tras esto
para que controle este objeto correctamente.
Lo que quiero decir, es que esta técnica que permite manipular este objeto,
con múltiples puntos de control, es algo totalmente nuevo.
Fue publicado en Siggraph recién el año pasado,
pero es un gran ejemplo del tipo de investigación que me encanta.
Todo este poder computacional aplicado a hacer que las cosas hagan las cosas correctas,
cosas intuitivas. Hacer exactamente lo que esperas.
Bueno, la interaccion multi-táctil es un campo muy activo ahora en la IPC (Interacción persona-computador)
No soy el único haciéndolo, hay muchas personas investigando.
Este tipo de tecnología va a permitir que aún más gente se interese,
y estoy muy ansioso de interactuar con todos ustedes
en los próximos días y ver cómo esto se puede aplicar a sus respectivos campos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)